jurassic park had cutting-edge visual
effects a great cast the magic touch of
steven spielberg and a memorable
soundtrack composed by none other than
john williams
despite the film's success and
continuing legacy there's a fatal flaw
behind the jurassic park franchise
the science jurassic park doesn't really
create dinosaurs so much as clone them
we're given the rundown as to how
exactly this miracle of science came to
be through a whimsical animated feature
in the first film
mr dna himself explains that blood
contains dna
and in order to make dinosaurs jon
hammond's expert squad of scientists had
to find dinosaur blood
fossilized mosquitoes and amber served
as the source for the park's collection
of dino dna
once the blood was collected from the
mosquitoes the dna was sequenced which
is a monumental task
geneticists sequenced the whole of the
dinosaur's genome and patched in missing
parts with dna from frogs with a
complete code for a dinosaur frog hybrid
jurassic park was then able to implant
the chromosomes into an a
tada you now have the makings of a baby
dinosaur disregarding the mind-boggling
amount of time it takes to sequence
a genome it seems like a fairly simple
process right not so fast author michael
crichton left some canon-sized gaps in
his otherwise very scientific
explanation as to how hammond
resurrected the long-dead dinosaurs
michael crichton is famous for his
fictional explorations of the furthest
reaches of science from resurrecting
dinosaurs to artificial intelligence to
time travel
his novels take a very serious
stringently researched approach to
science fiction
crichton leaves little up to
interpretation and explains in
excruciating detail the ins and outs of
how the science in his book should
theoretically work all this theory is
based on real peer-reviewed scientific
research
when creighton was writing jurassic park
he firmly believed that genetic
experimentation and manipulation was the
technology of the future
although not nearly as present in the
films the books show how various
corporations are willing to do whatever
it takes to make the next leap in
genetic engineering ethics be damned
this is a theme continued in other
novels such as next which questions
whether or not a living person sells can
be licensed and then owned by a
corporation
crichton had his finger on the pulse of
the latest in genetic engineering and in
some ways he was ahead of his time
what the well-paid highly qualified
folks at jurassic park are doing is
de-extinction
taking an extinct organism and cloning
it giving it life in the here and now
new gene editing capabilities previously
only seen in the movies are now
available to genetic researchers
allowing them to explore the real
possibilities of de-extinction
and no that doesn't mean we'll see a
real-life t-rex any time soon
but we might see something that looks
incredibly close to a real live woolly
mammoth a harvard team has been working
on splicing mammoth genes into the dna
of an asian elephant
the goal is to produce a hybrid mammoth
but there is no saying how long that
process might take
or if it ever gets approved due to the
ethical dilemma around resurrecting a
long-dead species
the closest science has come to a real
jurassic park scenario is the lazarus
project which successfully cloned
embryos of the extinct gastric brooding
frog in 2013. those embryos died after
just a few days but it's considered an
astounding
success that they ever lived at all the
whole concept of reviving dinosaurs in
jurassic park relies on the idea that
the fictional scientists can easily
extract dna from mosquitoes fossilized
in amber
this idea is unlikely at best impossible
at worst the books mention that jon
hammond has amber mines at his disposal
but even then how many bugs laden with
dino dna are those miners likely to find
not enough to supply a whole amusement
park with a previously extinct menagerie
even if hammond stumbled upon the mother
lode of frozen mosquitoes the dna within
them is not actually frozen in time
dna like all other organic material
decays
the reason why researchers think it's
more likely that they could clone a
mammoth is because their samples are
only around 4 000 years old rather than
66 million the jurassic park method of
extracting genetic material is unlikely
to supply geneticists with much if any
viable dna to work with the dinosaurs
would be more frog than terrible lizard
in the end
we're not gonna lie we'd still buy a
season pass to that park frogs are cool
jurassic park figured out how to create
dinosaur chromosomes but that's only
half the battle in 2013
scientists were able to get together the
complete genome of an extinct frog but
that particular pollywog isn't hopping
around today
that's because even with all the genetic
information the chromosomes have to be
implanted into an
embryo project lazarus embryos died
after a few days never producing a
viable fetus
so how did jurassic park do it this is
one of those details that crichton was
hoping we wouldn't look too closely at
wait a minute how do you interrupt the
cellular mitosis can we see the
unfertilized eggs
once you have the chromosomes for a
particular animal you still need eggs
the books claim that parent company
ingen had the tech to create artificial
eggs with artificial yolks into which
the dinosaur nucleus
is injected okay maybe this is another
moment where crichton is ahead of his
time the films however are way off base
they claim that they used unfertilized
ostrich or emu eggs
science shakes its knowledgeable head at
that a much closer relative would be
required
despite the fact that emus are just
about as intimidating as any
velociraptor
jurassic park made hard to pronounce
scientific names household words
velociraptor gallimimus pterodactyl and
the titular term jurassic
there is an interesting exclusion
however of the word cretaceous
the truth of the matter is that some of
the most famous names in dinosaur
history actually come from the
cretaceous period rather than the
jurassic period which
are separated by tens of millions of
years the tyrannosaurus rex triceratops
and velociraptor
are all firm residents of the cretaceous
period rather than the jurassic
den is into the jurassic with famous
bone structures with a stegosaurus
pterodactyl and the t-rex-esque
allosaurus
the cretaceous was the final era of
terrible lizards before the meteor
turned their meat into ash
so why is the park known as jurassic
park maybe crichton just thought it
sounded better than cretaceous park
it's definitely easier to spell the
revamped jurassic world features the
cretaceous cruise where vacationers can
kayak among the lazy-eyed stegosaurus
while the films give a basic explanation
as to why the park's all-female animals
were suddenly able to reproduce
the books go into deep detail as to how
a bunch of lady lizards were able to
start producing young without the help
of a male
this is yet another moment where
crichton was strangely ahead of his time
we find out in the books that thanks to
the frog dna spliced into the dinosaur
genes they were able to change their sex
and become male in order to mate
reptiles having so-called virgin births
is not unheard of and these scaly single
ladies don't even have to change their
sex
an all-female species of whip-tailed
lizard reproduces asexually
parthenogenesis the process of an
unfertilized egg reaching maturity and
ultimately hatching
has been observed in many reptile
species such as the dinosaur-like komodo
dragon for instance
raptors repopulating an abandoned theme
park life
finds a way jurassic park endorses that
somewhat dodgy practice of gene splicing
the films make it sound easy to fill in
the gaps where geneticists couldn't
complete the dna sequence jurassic park
chose frog dna to better acclimate the
eventual animals to the tropical climate
of isla
nublar no one really wants to see a
giant frog versus a scary scary dinosaur
jurassic world saw fit to mix it up and
make some super scary hybrids to impress
visitors
the indominus rex was made up of bits of
velociraptor cuttlefish pit viper tree
frog and a host of other dinosaurs
today in the real world it is
technically possible to make mutant
hybrids we do it with genetically
modified food but those anti-freezing
and disease-fighting traits borrowed
from other organisms aren't observable
like big bangs or camouflage
capabilities
adding in the genes capable of
expressing those features are one thing
flipping enough genetic switches so that
they are expressed as a wholly
mysterious as yet
undiscovered process we wouldn't know
how to make an indominus rex just
yet thank goodness as it turns out frogs
are what make the whole jurassic world
go round
in the movies it's the dna of these
familiar amphibians that has chosen to
fill in the genetic gaps of the
collected dinosaur genomes their traits
are desirable for acclimating the newly
resurrected animals to the tropical
island of isla nublar
and it's the amphibian ability to change
sex that led to the doom and destruction
of jurassic park
in jurassic world it's again the frog's
fault as to why everything got so
bloody so fast all the park's animals
have a little bit of frog in them but
the indominus rex was a little more
amphibian than others
some tree frogs namely the red snouted
tree frog blend into their background
so well that they are invisible in both
visible and infrared light
this cloaking ability is how the
indominus rex super smart and ultra
sneaky is able to pull its captors into
thinking that it disappeared from its
paddock
imagine a raptor likely the image
summoned to mind is of the stunning
practical effects from the first few
jurassic park films
wherein the velociraptors were speedy
man-sized monsters that had thick scales
and a packed mentality
this image is completely divorced from
the reality of what paleontologists have
unearthed about the species
brighton may have been confused when
writing about velociraptors one of
crichton's favorite research books
predatory dinosaurs of the world
mislabeled the bigger battered dino
nycas as a subspecies of velociraptor
dino nikes's description better fits the
creatures we see on the silver screen
whereas real velociraptors were small
flatty creatures no taller than around
three feet
recent paleontological finds suggest
that they were covered in feathers their
arms like wings
think big chicken rather than small
dragon for an accurate image of a
velociraptor
easily one of the most famous fallacies
popularized by the jurassic park films
is the idea that tyrannosaurus rex's
vision is based on movement
that's a comforting idea if you're
facing one of the big beasts but there
is little to no scientific evidence to
back up this hypothesis
that maybe his visual acuity is based on
movement like t-rex and
he'll lose you if you don't move dr alan
grant chooses a
let's say inopportune time to test this
theory when faced with a t-rex right
after the park's power is cut
disregarding the fact that the animal
can likely smell him in all his fear
the books take care to note that this
wasn't dr grant's theory but instead
another scientist
from what we know from real scientists
there's no credence whatsoever to the
idea that t-rex was anything other than
a smart sharp-eyed hunter
one who modern researchers agree also
had a great sense of smell and sound
considering that these facts weren't
discovered until over a decade after the
jurassic park book and movie we really
can't blame the writers or filmmakers
for exploring this theory
forget everything you think you know
about pack dynamics whether it's fluffy
wolves or scaly raptors
popular media has been misled about how
groups of deadly predators
interact and work together older
research that popularized the idea of an
alpha of the pack has recently been
proven inaccurate
in this flawed understanding the alpha
takes charge via displays of dominance
and force
the strongest rules over the weekends
and if there's a younger stronger
contender they can usurp the old alpha
and take over
this is what happens in jurassic world
when the indominus rex effectively
becomes the alpha of the raptor pack
however more recent studies show that
familial relationships take precedence
over power
the alpha is whichever animal is the
most like apparent to the rest of the
pack
thus it would make more sense in the
films that the raptor pack had stayed
loyal to owen grady who had raised them
since birth and long established himself
as the parent of the group
since the raptors had imprinted on him
the pax betrayal of him in favor of the
irex doesn't follow current
understanding of pack behavior
even with all the scientific errors and
misinformation that the books and film
spread we have to give a lot of credit
to the jurassic park
franchise for making science cool
paleontology and genetic engineering was
put on a worldwide platform the films
not only introduced impressionable kids
to an interesting career path
but they also opened the door to
increased funding of the sciences
following the release of the first film
paleontologists and archaeologists
enjoyed what has been called the
jurassic park phase
where an enthusiasm for fossils and the
pursuit of dino dna was more ardent than
ever
whether you like them cuddly or cruel
ferocious
or fluffy there's no doubt dinosaurs
have roared back from extinction
around this time great leaps and bounds
were made in research into de-extinction
and discoveries that would have usually
gone unnoticed by the popular press like
the sequencing of an ancient weevils dna
became sensational
however the film's focus on
de-extinction has also been implicated
as a distraction why should we try to
revive dead animals when there are
living ones in need of protection
regardless as to whether jurassic park's
legacy has been a help or a hindrance to
the scientific community
its influence is undeniable check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one